lamelo great closeout win for you guys
tonight um this is the second or third
time this season where you guys have
just made all the right decisions down
the stretch this one resulted in a win
uh take us through the crunch time
moments going into overtime your
mentality when you guys were down by as
much as 18 yeah pretty much just
everybody was locked in we knew we was
on like a little losing streak or been
losing and whatnot so we know this a
great team to you know get a win against
so we just all pulled in and we was like
we got to get this win if we want to
change something you know make something
happen so let's all just lock in right
now and that's pretty much what happened
lamelo Sam M you here after a win like
this they interviewed miles Bridges and
he talked about this is the type of win
that could Propel you guys you guys are
starting to get healthy do you look at a
game like this and say guys our
potential if we can beat this team and
play this way and play mistake free down
the stretch what can we be is that the
message you're going to be preaching to
this young team going forward yeah
exactly I mean coach already preaching
it everybody preaching it even uh coming
in we he said we get this win you you
know that could change a lot I mean it's
a real great team everybody know about
him so just coming in getting this win
was real big lamelo congrats on the win
man that was a heck of a finish down the
stretch for your group you know
obviously the season hadn't gotten off
to the start you wanted what do you feel
like has been holding you guys back thus
far in terms of the start You' gotten
off
to uh pretty much I mean injuries a lot
of that stuff you know people just not
being healthy but I feel like we finally
getting there you know everybody been
playing chemistry getting there so you
know we just like I said we just going
to keep going uh you mentioned the wins
right and I think of your first year
your rookie season you win rookie of the
year next year you get 43 wins and I'm
like okay this team is ascending of
course last year you got injured and
that wasn't the case uh how difficult
has it been for you this season knowing
the success you had when you were
healthy and trying to get back to that
track of coming up in the league uh yeah
pretty much you know I'm real confident
with myself I know who I am and I know
what I'm capable of so just I had the
little ankle issue but I knew that was
going to hold me back so I just you know
like I said I'll just keep going lamelo
ball again close to a triple double 36
points nine rebounds eight assists thank
you for stopping by game time we
appreciate you my friend I appreciate
y'all thank you
man